thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
stick around to the end to get more than
40 off
warhammer is a game that needs at least
two people to play
and this year that's been a bit
difficult covid has put a complete
dampener on my tabletop gaming
activities this year
and yes you can do stuff through
tabletop simulator but
it's not the same as playing with real
plastic crack
while artificial intelligence may be
feared in the grim darkness of the far
future fortunately today not so much
and using a little bit of programming
knowledge you can crudely approximate an
ai so i used machine learning techniques
to teach my computer how to play
warhammer 40 000.
well not full fat 40k that's a bit
complicated instead i taught my computer
how to play
kill team kill team is the small scale
skirmish version of games workshop's
warhammer 40 000.
so this is a tabletop game played with
miniatures and dice
a game of kill team consists of two or
more though i'm definitely limiting it
to two
two or more teams of models from the
same faction competing to achieve their
objectives
so a game for example might consist of
these hawaiian orcs
versus these space marines each model on
each of the teams can then do a variety
of actions in a specific order as
dictated by
the rules a model can move as many
inches as its move characteristic allows
which was
six inches for example for space marines
whereas hormones over here from high
fleet nostromo
they're a bit faster so they can move
eight inches after moving a model then
has the ability to
shoot whatever weapons it has so a model
arm with for example a heavy bolter
which is a heavy anti-personnel weapon
gets a very high chance of taking out an
enemy
whilst a model only armed with a pistol
has a relatively slim chance the chance
of course is where the dice come in
so a model will roll a dice to see if it
hits their enemy
it will then roll another dice if they
do hit see if they
wound and then the model that has been
hit gets to roller dice to see if their
armor protects them from that wound
all of these roles are informed by the
characteristics of the models so
a space moon has a very high armor save
whilst a orc is basically wearing a
t-shirt but
is quite tough so it can still shrug
runes on the six all of this is to say
that a game of kill team is basically
nothing more than a very complicated
algorithm a series of instructions that
you execute one after the other with
some
randomness injected by the dice so in
theory it would be possible to codify
the
rules of kill team in computer code such
that a computer could read it
the first step then in creating my
machine opponent was to convert
the rules of kill team into a form that
the computer can read and understand
so i chose to do that in python code
here in rulebook.py
uh we have the rules of kill team just
put into python code form the largest
part of this file is the sequence of
events that take place in the battle so
you
roll two dice each to see who goes first
whoever rolls highest goes first and
then the first team you get to do all
their movement the second team gets to
do all their movement and then you go
through the shooting phase the assault
phase and then
morale at the end of the turn to
accomplish this the first thing i had to
do was to create a virtual battlefield
that the battles could take place on
so this class here battlefield is a grid
as well as lots of other information it
basically contains a grid
that tells us where each model is and if
at a particular point in the battlefield
there is a model of one team the other
team
nothing or if there's terrain which is
going to block line of sight so what
i've done is discretized the space i've
turned it from a continuous
thing because obviously you don't just
move in one inch blocks on the
battlefield but
to allow the computer to wrap its head
around it i had to discretize it
and this was the easiest way to do that
i should hold my hands up as well and
say that i have made some
simplifications it's not
full kill team because there are several
things which were just too complicated
to put in so
stratagems for example there are no
specialists so no heavies no leaders no
demolitions people just because i could
have put them in but i wanted to get
this video done before christmas and
sleep before then and thirdly the
mission that's being fought in this
imaginary battlefield is the simplest
one possible you're just trying to kill
every other model on the other team
so there's no holding of objectives
again i could have put that in but it
was just extra complexity and
i really needed to get this video done
the most crucial part this whole
procedure was identifying where
decisions
are made so where as a human are you
actually exercising
agency rather than just going with what
the dice tell you to do
so one obvious example of that is where
a model moves so a model can choose to
charge a model if it's in range
or it could just choose to move normally
which would allow it to shoot later
in the turn so as a human you need to
determine where your model is going to
go based on a bunch of
information like you know what other
models are around uh what weapon do you
have are you a model that is good in
close combat or
bet is better at shooting all of this
determines whether you're going to stay
still and shoot
move in behind cover or run towards the
enemy so whether or not a model is going
to
make a normal move is one decision
whether or not you're going to charge
with a model is a separate decision
because they're two different kinds of
movement
and then lastly who you're going to
shoot with a model out of all the
possible
targets you have is another decision the
computer makes a decision at each one of
these points
based on a model which is where the
machine learning comes into it so
basically it takes in a bunch of inputs
so
here for example in the shooting model
it takes in the inputs of how far
is the model from its target what is the
model's ballistic skill what is its
weapons range how many attacks does it
have so in other words how good is it in
close combat all of this kind of stuff
that then gets fed into a model which
returns a probability
and that probability is how likely is it
the model is going to take that
action so what it does is consider all
possible actions that it could take
every place it could move to every model
it could shoot for example
and it ranks them from the most likely
to the least likely starting from the
most likely outcome the computer then
generates a random number between zero
and
one and basically if that number is less
than
the probability that the action is taken
the model takes that action so if the
model has a probability of 0.9 of firing
at a given
uh enemy model there's a 90 chance that
it will do so so when it generates a
random number like 0.25
that means that it will decide to take
that action the model then goes through
all of the possible outcomes until it
hits something that actually does
take place the random number generator
says that oh that is the action that
we're going to take
or it reaches the end of the list in
which case it doesn't do anything it
doesn't move or it doesn't shoot
the question then becomes what is this
model this shoot model in this
particular example how does it take
those inputs and
arrive at a probability the answer to
that is basically just a bunch of
maths it's a bunch of linear algebra to
be precise so this file contains
the algorithms that are used and all
they are is basically a bunch of
matrices
and vectors that you take in the inputs
you multiply by a matrix add a vector to
it
and you repeat that twice because this
is effectively a multi-layer perceptron
model so the probability of an action
being taken
associated with a given input vector is
then purely determined by the values
in these matrices in control rods and in
bias
and those values are effectively how the
model makes its decisions that's its
decision-making process encoded into
just a
couple of arrays all of this then gets
brought together in this
master python file so this takes
information from the rulebook
uh about how battles are for it takes
information from the machine learning
algorithms file about how these models
work
and it simulates a bunch of battles in
fact if i run this right now
it will simulate one you'll notice that
i added
names to keep track of individual models
that was useful for debugging but i also
find it kind of funny
did so for the sound effects
[Applause]
now the decision making you're seeing
here by these models
is basically random and that's because
those matrices and vectors in the
machine learning algorithms that
initialize that the first
starting values are just random numbers
between naught and
one and so the probability of a given
action being taken by a model here
is pretty much just a random outcome
so we need to train this model in order
to learn how to play it knows the rules
but doesn't know how to play
well but i'm not going to teach it how
to do that
i'm going to let it teach itself
specifically i'm going to use a
technique
known as reinforcement learning and
what's called a genetic
algorithm but what do those terms mean
so reinforcement learning is where you
develop
a essentially reward based model so you
have a model that's
looking to find a what's usually called
a policy
that optimizes for the greatest reward
so most
video game machine learning algorithms
uh
models that have been developed to win
games like chess
are reinforcement learning style models
genetic algorithms
basically trying to model natural
selection so you
breed a set of models and you
try them out and then you take the ones
that do well and
essentially use those to breed new
models based on the parameters that
already work well you usually add
some sort of permutation to that model
um in order to help you
explore the parameter space a little bit
more maybe hit on something that
what is currently best doesn't capture
um and then keep iterating through that
until you find a model that you have
determined is the best
this is jordan harrod a phd student in
machine learning at mit
she has a fantastic youtube channel all
about machine learning and artificial
intelligence which you should absolutely
check out
it's got an introduction to machine
learning as well as featuring some
interesting experiments
she agreed to help me on this project
giving some advice on how to make the
model
as effective as possible for people who
are watching this my extent of
knowledge on this game is like watching
a few simon videos so
not a ton but so there may be ways to
like initialize your weights that like
you are aware of that
would help you converge to a solution
faster
um okay yeah but yeah when it comes to i
think that there's a difference between
like
coding for scale and coding for fun and
when it comes to coding for fun
you don't need to use fancy models you
can just brute force it there's
some amount of utility in developing
systems where you know exactly what each
part is doing
um in the sense that kind of circling
back to what i mentioned earlier in the
sense of like
making sure that the problem that you're
trying to solve is actually the problem
that you're solving
like i can look at this and be like yes
you were developing a model that like
scores high at this game and like i know
that and you know that whereas
other types of models um because things
are a bit more abstracted it can
you have to be a lot more deliberate
about how you set things okay so that's
interesting so i think maybe the thing i
need to do going into this is
but up until now the inputs have been
slightly haphazard but i think actually
if i know what the inputs are and i have
an intuition for
for example like the algorithm that
determines if a model
is going to move to a location there
should be like a negative feedback
between
the number of enemy models that can see
you in that location
and the probability that you will move
there
you know like basically nothing about
this game but sure okay
that sounds correct okay good as long as
it sounds correct that's fine
but okay so basically i need to go away
and think about what the input vector is
and how i anticipate the model should
react to that
and that gives the genetic algorithm
kind of like a head start on
finding the best possible approach yeah
in general it helps to
initialize models if you have any sort
of intuition about like
how the model should converge um
and like part of that is also making
sure that like what you think the model
should do is actually
what the model should be doing because
there may be other things that you're
not aware of but
um just in terms of like optimization
efficiency
like instead of having to you know run
a thousand loops maybe you only have to
run a hundred loops because you're just
already that much closer
yeah um to where you need to end up so
folding jordan's advice
into the code it was time to let the
model train
i left the code running overnight with
150 models in each generation we got
through over 50
generations each one bringing iterative
improvements the computer
getting better and better at beating
itself
at kilty the question is is it good
enough
to beat a professional nerd
let's find out this is the battlefield
we're going to be duking
out over so this is a normal kill team
board and what i've done is put a piece
of plastic over the top
with a grid and some coordinates along
both axes
and this basically allows me to take
what's in
the computer's virtual battlefield and
project onto a real battlefield so we
both have the same information me and
the computer
apologies that this camera angle is a
little bit
cockeyed the kits are getting on a bit
and limitations of space
sorry the computer of course has its own
virtual battlefield i coded up a basic
graphic user interface so that it will
show that same grid
where the models are and it allows me to
interact with it so i can select a model
and tell it to move or to charge whether
i'm done with that model
now you may notice that i have no dice
here and that's because all the random
number generation is going to be taking
place in the computer
now wargaming fans may say well that
doesn't really work because
when your enemy shoots at you they roll
their dice to hit and wound and then you
roll your dice to save and
yeah i hear you but a that'll be a pain
in the ass to code
and b whether they roll an imaginary
dice in a random number generator or eye
roll a physical dice
doesn't actually make any difference
because we're not having any command
point rerolls it's literally just
random number generation so all i have
to do the only agency i
have in this game is exactly what the
computer has
choosing where to move where to charge
and who to shoot
everything else is just coded into the
algorithm and up to the
luck of the random number generator now
this battlefield would be pretty boring
to fight over because it's just a flat
plane
so what i'm going to do is add some
terrain and then input that into the
computer so that we both have the same
information about where line of sight is
where cover is all that kind of stuff
and then we can see if the student has
become
the master i really hope not please
don't turn out to be skynet
okay apologies if the audio sounds a bit
different i had a minor crisis with the
program it broke
i then stepped on my microphone so we're
working with a backup
one change of coordinates later we have
our final battlefield and now i need to
put the miniatures where the computer
has deployed them
which is random within the deployment
zones marius
you're the plasma gunner you are at e3
i always wanted to go though s7 and then
that leaves agnathio this was the first
space moon i ever painted so he's got a
special place in my heart
please don't die uh he's a f3
okay and the orcs uh starting with chris
trot knob
l23 v24
j27 okay sick we're deployed
this is how things went down in the
first turn the orcs surged up the board
going mid
shagrat fired a rocket and flesh-wounded
navair my heavy weapons marine and in
response
we had a dismal shooting phase only
taking out one
orc in turn two the orcs continued to
pound up the board and korros my
sergeant counter-charged to get the
initiative in the fight phase
we chipped a wound off their boss knob
chris trot but otherwise achieved
nothing in the shooting phase and
nothing in the fight phase
as the dice absolutely refused to go my
way
then in the third turn everything went
wrong
i attempted to preempt the charge from
chris trot and believed the model would
split the rest of its forces and go for
my marines on the left side
right side and center but instead just
dog piled my sergeant in the center
this left much of my firepower
ineffective my marines were at position
most orcs were locked in combat and so
unable to be shot but
nevaeh was able to snipe shagger at
exacting revenge for his rocket attack
earlier
unfortunately nevaeh then bought the
farm due to some wild slugger fire from
orcs who hadn't actually charged but
were just
in the center just orcs sniper things my
brave charging marine torvar then got
his face caved in by chris trott
though miraculously my sergeant survived
he was still pauldron deep in orcs
though
in turn 4 i had the opportunity to blast
away with my firepower
which i completely squandered with yet
more abysmal dice rolls
not a single awk dropped due to our
extensive firepower
koros was able to take out ross hornby
in the fight phase though
and somehow weathered the storm of
attacks in return
by turn five things were looking grim
korros disengaged and
signaled his battle brothers to open
fire on the pile of orcs in the center
unfortunately they had all loaded phone
bullets instead of 75 caliber shells
and not a single orc was killed yet
again the dice gods were not with me
they were with the orcs though who just
casually dropped gunnar over on the left
flank
turn six crunch time for some reason the
model chose to largely stand still and
shoot perhaps confused by the
distribution of targets which left me a
window of opportunity
if i just took out three t-shirt clad
orcs
i would draw on points the blood was
pounding in my veins this was it
time for the wrath of the adeptus
astartes to be visited upon these orcs
just kidding we couldn't hit anything
not a single orc went down
and with that that's it it's over
i lost i lost my own computer program
what is this the circle is now complete
when i left you i was but the learner
now i
am the master i am truly sorry humanity
but i think i may have doomed us
all this isn't exactly how i wanted this
to go
for a number of reasons the battle
reports i watch on youtube
are very long which is very different
from the content i make on this channel
if i uploaded a multi-hour battle report
it would completely screw my statistics
and tank my channel's algorithmic
ranking
being so dependent on the youtube
algorithm is a major job in security for
youtubers like me fortunately i was able
to upload a greatly extended version of
this video including more discussion
with jordan
and a comprehensive battle report over
on nebula a coalition of youtubers
including
tiazu jordan real engineering and lady
knight the brave
and me created nebula as a place where
we can upload the content we want
to make not the content the youtube
algorithm
says we should make we're free to
experiment create new formats and
collaborate with each other in mega
series like working
titles breaking down the title sequences
of our favorite shows
we also upload the content that we
upload to youtube early to nebula so you
get early access on the site
but that's not the best bit there are
absolutely
no adverts on the site no auto playing
ads
no ad reads at the end of videos the
site runs on a subscription fee that is
divided up among creators according to
how much watch time their content
received it's fairer for us
and a better viewing experience for you
we've partnered up with curiositystream
the number one provider of high quality
documentaries on the internet from
how to build a castle to amazing gravity
with jim alcali with a special deal for
a limited time you can get access to
curiosity streams
immense library and nebula for not 40
but 41 off that's less than 12
a year to not see adverts on your
favorite youtube content
to support your favorite creators and to
get the best library
of long-form documentaries on the web go
to curiositystream.com forward slash
simon clark and sign up doing so you
support your own learning
and the community of online educators
that's curiositystream.com
forward slash simon clark thank you so
much for watching the video i really
hope you enjoyed watching it as much as
i enjoyed making it
this project was very much the center of
the venn diagram of my nerdy interests
from
programming to warhammer to youtube
here's some suggested viewing for the
next half hour of your life
and if you enjoyed this video please do
pop it a like leave a comment and you
can always subscribe if you want to see
more stuff like this
i think that just leaves me to say um
thank you again for watching
i'll see you in the next one happy
festag